hi Miele i'm ron wyatt this is my friend  steve cook we've been friends for six  years old you know I heard you were  going on a little date with sergeant  Scott more US Marines and I say God  bless america that is fantastic and I  got to tell you I didn't know who you  were and then somebody said what did you  see the movie Black Swan and I said no  when they rented it for me and I'd like  to go on a date with you also now I know  what you're saying Ron you're a married  man but I got a Hall Pass my wife gave  me a Hall Pass didn't you honey sure  yeah see you there and I think that that  Steve's going to get along with Natalie  I didn't go out on a little double date  think about it let us know